(light music)
(ringing)
- Hi!
Ah, it's really you.
- Hi, Bridge.
- What time is it over there?
- Oh, I don't know; late.
- Shit, I'm sorry.
I should have checked.
- No, I wanted to talk to you.
So you got there okay?
- Yeah, I just got to my dorm.
Look.
- Cool.
- Yeah.
My roommate's not here yet.
Oh my god, I'm so nervous.
I miss you already.
- Aw, don't worry Bridge.
Everything's gonna be okay.
(screeching)
(light music)
- The room looks good.
- Yeah, I know.
I guess it just needed
some pictures of us.
Oh, my roommate just walked in.
You can meet her.
Kelly.
- Hi, I'm Kelly.
I've heard a lot about you.
- Hi!
Nice to meet you.
Make sure you take care of her.
- It's just really hard,
like everyone's already got their friends
and I'm all on my own
because of the dumb time I transferred.
- Oh Bridge I'm sorry.
I wish I was there.
- Yeah, and things aren't like at home.
Like they call crisps
chips and chips fries
and what the hell is a
dime compared to a quarter?
- (Laughing) I wish I
could give you a hug.
Things will get easier; I swear.
(melancholic music)
(whooshing)
- Yeah, so Samantha' gonna
come costume shopping with me
for the 80's party.
- Who's Samantha?
- Oh she's just a girl from college.
She's in Andy's psychology class.
- Oh cool.
- Yeah, anyway, so she's gonna get a tutu,
but I don't think I'm going to
because I don't really
want to let my leg out
because it's cold.
I was gonna get neon tights
and maybe like a skater dress.
- Hey.
- Oh hey, I met you at that party.
- Yeah, Madison.
- I am Bridgette.
Yeah, that party kind of sucked, right?
- Yeah, not my favorite.
- Yeah and she's coming
over in a bit to hang out.
- Oh that's awesome.
See I told you you'd make friends.
(laughing)
(phone ringing)
- Oh my god, she's so funny.
Did you see her SNL episode last year?
- Yes!
Oh my god, yeah you're right.
- So good.
(laughing)
(birds tweeting)
(phone ringing)
- Come on, answer.
- Answer.
(phone ringing)
- I didn't realize you were
in my American Lit class.
- Yep, I was supposed
to take it as a Freshman
but just getting (mumbling).
- I really like Mr. Abrams.
- Pretty cool.
- Oh, I have him.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, he's actually really good.
I like him a lot.
- Hi, where have you been?
- I just got busy.
You didn't answer either.
- Because I got busy too.
I wanted some advice actually.
Eric's being a total shithead again.
I don't know why I stay with him.
Anyway, Samantha ended up
talking with me about it.
- Oh, well at least you have Samantha.
Look, I'm late for class.
- Okay.
- [Professor] (indistinct
speech) clearly before us.
- Are you guys going to
that concert on Saturday?
- No, my frat's having a party.
- Oh, boo.
What about you Bridge?
Bridgette?
- What?
- Yeah, I miss you too, but look at us
we're all grown up and shit.
(laughing)
Yeah, yeah, I'll talk to you later.
Okay, bye.
(melancholic music)
(birds tweeting)
(upbeat music)
- Oh, morning.
- Hey, you want to get
breakfast before class?
- Yeah, totally.
Let's do it.
(upbeat music)